today many Americans don't like
capitalism socialism would be better
they say not repressive Russian or
Venezuelan socialism but democratic
socialism like what's practiced in
Scandinavia I think we should look to
countries like Denmark like Sweden say
what do you want to be like Sweden kinda
sounds pretty good people interviewed in
this just released PBS documentary say
America should be more like Sweden it
seems like is that good place that make
no problem do something it is a
socialist economy Volvos and
socialized medicine at Volvo is now a
Chinese company welcome to Stockholm
Sweden my name is Joe and norburg and
this is where I was born and raised
Johan Norberg made this documentary
because he wanted to set the record
straight
Sweden is not socialist because the
government doesn't own the means of
production to see that you have to go to
Venezuela or to Cuba or North Korea but
we did have a period in the 1970s and
1980s when we had something that
resembled socialism big government that
taxed and spend heavily and that's the
period in Swedish history when our
economy was going south so much so that
even socialists complained about the
high taxes a steel Indian who wrote the
very popular children's books people
Longstocking for instance she she was a
social democrat but she had made a lot
of money from her books she found that
she paid a hundred and two percent in
taxes she wrote this angry essay about a
witch who was quite mean and vicious but
not at all as vicious as the swedish tax
authorities and yet even though taxes
were high they did not bring in enough
money to fund Sweden's welfare state
there were waiting lines to get health
care people couldn't get the pension
that they thought that they depended on
for the future at that point the the
Swedish population just said enough we
can't do this Sweden then reduced
government's role they cut public
spending and privatized the national
rail network abolished certain
government monopolies eliminated
inheritance taxes and sold state-owned
businesses like the maker of Absolut
Vodka lower taxes reform the pension
system so that it wasn't unsustainable
the results from the spending cuts and
privatization this impoverished peasants
nation developed into one of the world's
richest countries
all I hear is it Sweden is this
socialist paradise we do have a bigger
welfare state than the u.s. higher taxes
than the US but in other areas when it
comes to free markets when it comes to
competition when it comes to free trade
Sweden is actually more free market that
free market pays for Sweden's big
welfare programs today our taxes pay for
pensions you call it Social Security for
18 month paid parental leave government
paid child care for working families but
having the government manage all of
these things didn't work well so we had
to manage it in another way
they've privatized we realized in Sweden
that with these government monopolies we
don't get the innovation that we get
when we have competition and this is
particularly true for the school system
Sweden switched to a school voucher
system that lets parents pick their kids
school and forces schools to compete and
one of the results that we've seen is
not just that the private schools are
better than the public ones but even the
public schools in the vicinity of
private schools they often improve
because they have to Sweden's version of
social security was going broke
so Sweden privatized that to privatize
the pension system that terrifies people
and obviously that scares people but
when they realize that the alternative
was that the whole pension system would
collapse they thought that this is much
better than nothing now the bulk of
pensions is really contribution defined
so if things are going well for Sweden
pensions are increasing but if things
are going less well pensions are
automatically lowered which basically
takes away from politicians the ability
to buy votes by just promising higher
pensions and letting future generations
pay and when it comes to taxes what
Sweden does may surprise you the low
income earners in Sweden pay a lot more
than low income earners in the mirror
so despite the fact that Sweden looks
like sort of a socialist country which
taxes rich exorbitantly hi
the truth is the opposite people who
were in below average income pay up to
60% in taxes this is the dirty little
secret about the Swedish tax system we
don't take from the rich and give to the
poor we squeeze the poor because they
are loyal taxpayers not taking more from
the rich school choice privatization
Sweden is anything but socialists you
can turn your backs to the to the well
to the creation of wealth you can watch
the full documentary Sweden lessons for
America at free to choose TV